we have now heard from multiple
authoritative voices from a former NORAD
Commander to the former dni to a former
F-18 Navy pilot who all say that what's
been happening in or near our airspace
is very serious
from a national security standpoint we
all should be incredibly concerned
you're also seeing the Confluence of a
despic distinctive activity by our
adversaries to test our systems it looks
like a coordinated effort we literally
have uh things above our heads uh that
we're now shooting down with our own
assets we all deserve an answer of what
they are
now it certainly isn't something that
should be kind of laughed off
I know there have been questions and and
concerns about this but there is no
again no indication of aliens or
extraterrestrial activity with these
recent takedowns I'm just you know I
loved E.T the movie but I'm just gonna
leave it there
certainly shouldn't be casually
dismissed with maybes or might bees or
could bees
these very well could be balloons of a
completely benign nature based on the
flight characteristics uh the visual
confirmation by the pilots and some
other data that we're putting to it one
sort of well leading into indication
could be uh that they were actually
benign balloons
oh my God how is he employed it's a
little premature to make these
pronouncements since Biden's own
Pentagon Chief said they haven't been
able to recover anything
now the fact is our adversaries most
notably China
have been working hard to get the
surveillance Edge on us but they're
going to do it by any means necessary
from embedding spies and CCP foot
soldiers into our universities to
stealing our technology and then reverse
engineering it
now the administration tried to save
Faith Yesterday by leaking to The
Washington Post and CBS that they'd been
tracking that first spy balloon the
whole time since it left China
my question tonight is why would anyone
believe that
the only thing we know for sure is that
Biden blinken and Harris do not want
anything not even Chinese spying to
interfere with their desire to Cozy up
to China
this is what their donors want and this
is what big business wants and we see
this playing out on the state level as
well
some of our oldest corporations are
eager to attract Chinese investment a
few weeks back Republican Governor Glenn
Younkin smartly rejected Ford Motor
Company's plan to build batteries in
Virginia citing its collaboration with a
Chinese entity
but Michigan and Ford they don't care
the battery Venture will happen there
just two weeks ago Ford's CEO Jim Farley
announced this company lost about two
billion dollars over the previous year
gotta make up for that shortfall
somewhere so who cares if it comes at
the expense of American independence
and of course Michigan Governor Gretchen
whitless Whitmer couldn't pass up the
chance to take a Victory lap of
returning her State over to the CCP
we are coming together to celebrate a
big win for team Michigan we're going to
make electric vehicles top to bottom
right here in the great state of
Michigan and I am grateful to Ford
but if everyone really cared about
creating good paying jobs should be
pushing tonight for more Drilling and
more fracking which would actually make
us stronger than and not more dependent
on China
Chris Barry an independent energy
analyst who tracks mineral markets he
doesn't seem concerned with what this
means for American markets instead he
took a shot at junkin's move claiming
that he was just throwing some red meat
to his base
red meat
well Fox exclusively reported today that
the CEO of contemporary ampharettes
technology the Chinese company that's
partnering with Ford is tied directly to
the CCP so-called united front influence
campaign
but of course don't expect to hear from
our hologram president you know he's not
going to raise any concern about any of
this
first it's not clear he follows any of
this closely or even understands it and
second from what we've seen on Hunter's
laptop there's every reason to believe
that he and his family are compromised
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else